on poursuit cette page loisir avec vos
idées de sortie dans les ivelines
Gabriel qu'est-ce que vous nous proposez
ce soir bon vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
Mathilde que halloween c'est fini mais
pourquoi pas prolonger la fête samedi
l'association villeeverte propose aux
plus téméraires de venir venir écouter
des histoires terrifiante tout ça au
cœur de la forêt départementale de la
Madeleine une façon de découvrir la
Vallée de Chevreuse d'une manière
originale et faire vivre encore un peu
hallowen et alors après ces histoires
effrayantes Gabriel vous nous plongez
dans une ambiance un peu plus américaine
oui l'association plaisir plaisiroise
cowboy at dancer propose son
traditionnel bal et concert country au
programme démonstration et initiation à
la danse country mais aussi concert
proposé par le groupe country rock rock
and chairs si ça vous intéresse Mathilde
il ne vous reste plus qu'à revêtir votre
chapeau et vos santiague je vais
peut-être devoir aussi réviser quelques
pasedans peut-être on poursuit vos idées
de sortie Gabriel avec une
traditionnelle course yvelinoise oui la
course royale de Fontenet lefleur
revient s lançant de la pièce d'eau des
Suisses pour rejoindre Fontenet le fleur
coureur expérimentés ou famille en quête
de nouvelles expérience il y a forcément
une course pour vous cette année proposé
un semi-marathon un 10,m5 mais aussi une
course familiale des dossards seront à
gagner durant la course pour participer
au 10 km du marathon pour tous de Paris
2024 et on termine Gabriel avec deux
exposition la première se trouve à
Versailles oui nourrir le soldat au
front c'est l'intitulé de l'exposition
que propose la ville de Versailles
constitué de textes de photos de cartes
postales issu d'archives l'exposition
retrace l'histoire de l'alimentation des
soldats alliés et du soldat allemand
durant la Première Guerre mondiale une
immersion dans une facette méconnue de
l'histoire mais riche d'information sur
la vie des soldats au front et la
deuxième exposition que vous nous
proposez Gabriel elle se trouve à
Clairefontaine oui le Centre d'art La
Chapelle rend hommage à Bruno Barbet en
mettant à l'honneur les photographies du
photo journaliste l'exposition
s'intitule palette
méditerranéenne du Portugal au Maroc à
travers son objectif Bruno Barbet a
passé sa carrière à photographier la
diversité culturelle et l'authenticité
du pourtour méditerranéen donnant
naissance à des clichés colorés et
nuancés l'exposition matiil est à
découvrir jusqu'au 25 février et bien
merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces idées de sortie